[Music]
I've mentioned this before I'm gonna
mention again let's talk about the
campaign apparently President Obama and
Mitt Romney are both struggling to come
up with slogans that are as effective as
Obama's 2008 slogan change you can
believe in and that was an amazing
slogan they're both looking for a slogan
that good for 2012 well this week Obama
and Romney tried out a new batch of
slogans they're really trying to come up
with a good one I have to say they're
getting mixed results I laid out a
blueprint for an economy that is built
to last
we believe in our shelves our greatest
days are ahead the family that's
struggling to get by is having to do
more because I'm doing less guess what
I've made a lot of money I'll declare
I'm a total bumbling idiot guess who's
gonna pay that not me I'm gone it's
every American for themselves I believe
that America is just another place on
the map with a flag anybody here can
afford to pay an extra thousand dollars
right now
I don't think I have any comments on on
qualifications for individuals to serve
in various positions in government at
this stage I like a slogan anyone got
$1,000 right now that's true one I would
go with